hey guys let's go get to steveandjenna
and today we are gonna be making ice
cream I love ice cream and I love ice
cream so much the video that we did on
Jenna's channel a while ago we made that
rolled ice cream my god the peppermint
rolled ice cream we're not allowed to
make it we found that I was like we
can't make it because I could not
control my I mean she was drinking it it
wasn't even in the ice cream form it was
just a liquid and she was like gotta
strong things happened I have the worst
stomachache ever and we're not gonna
make that mistake again
but today Wow have you picked this up
yeah I picked it up decided here we are
making ice cream we are going to be
using a ball now you basically put ice
cream mix into this ball and then you
put ice on the other side of it and then
you roll the ball for about 20 minutes
and then guess what you have ice cream I
did that earlier and I knocked over
would you drink it um this is ice cream
solvent yeah this is recommended on
Amazon but man this box has been
destroyed this is if you want to take
your ball in the pool so don't flow are
you wait wait wait it's implantable well
we don't need that right now you wanna
blow this for me
yo I hate it hurts my ears shoot me too
well we might not listen up we might not
inflate our balls but that penology in
play that crap this is a thing well we
might have to I'll blow it I'm so
confused
well let me explain to you I'm confused
I don't have to do that we can just kick
this around is it did you freeze it
that's not how it works so there's two
sides one of the sides you put the
obvious and the other side you put the
green this is fun I wish I can invent
some fun
oh it's a little dirty yeah it does
something fair well you don't eat from
this side this is where the ice goes
this does look dirty
what are you watching I've got questions
I feel like this is fake they scooped
that right out of that Breyers candle
yeah but I just don't feel like this is
a fitting for like what this is like
it's just a beard picture okay anyway I
can't get over this big big big oh no
you can't make it a big mint because I
can't control myself oh cool I'm gonna
wash this because I'm gonna want to eat
this ice cream all right I will
investigate what we do
welcome interactions with a basic
vanilla I think we need a pint of cream
Oh
pure and simple recycle a spec vanilla
yep line up lines of cream yes pint
oh that's what is your pass wait wait
one third oh really
one third cup I thought I said one one
third cup Wow
good thing you're here this isn't gonna
come from an extract you have a little
bit yep one in one half to sugar up
everywhere that moves that I don't know
what that was how much was that well why
are you doing that because one of the
things that you're doing right now I'm
putting a little vanilla in there well
don't use that because I use that um oh
yeah that's the problem
I use this unbox stuff it's not clean
pardon me Holly burst into flames
pardon me well at first I didn't really
had a ready to roll doing rice in the
bowl yeah get break at the ice ready
pour the mixture into the metal sill
into the plot for expansion this is
where putting the ice and the cylinder
inside of it is where the ice cream goes
I don't want to drop the ball on this
one
oh yeah hold up straight put it about an
inch give it that's an inch
yes yeah yeah it's good it's good enough
so now what we're gonna do it's gonna
close this up you don't want our cream
coming yeah now we're home we gotta go
play with the ball what does Maddie's
gonna like it I'll be rolling this and
all of his pee that's disgusting
well it's facts put the foot they've
left let's put the inflator on light it
up this is like did you like
[Music]
Oh God yeah breathe let's just go around
Oh
[Music]
you're covering to put the ball in its
protective gear it just goes like this
then you this is absolutely ridiculous
can you imagine having this at a pool
party
tight squeeze around this book
which is fun
[Applause]
so it's done yet
oh I quit oh I don't think I'm ready
this is still this is not even cold I
think we still have like 10 minutes to
go Oh Oh God rush tips you realize you
just like the boy I just lick the ball
you guys like the book you guys are just
like dog pee I just rolled this ball I'm
crap what do I do
all right what do I do I want to make us
ice cream you know there's a dryer that
is an absolutely incredible idea except
it'll break your dryer it's just an
empty out some of the water from the ice
I think I'm enjoying it am i immature
[Music]
slow turn doesn't say rolled around and
jog through all but if I put it on like
this is a bad idea
you look miserable this is what I look
like it's a lock
and we've been doing this really 20
minutes or so and I don't want to do it
anymore
here we go it's so good here take a bite
of you they'll give me the camera
think about a few go this is rolling
around and poop and pee no Mary so I
will say that if I had more patience
this would work really well I'm quite
impressed if you guys want to check this
out put a link the description into
Amazon where you can get it this is not
sponsored I bought this because I
thought it was gonna be a lot more fun
but I'll tell you what ma'am absolute
work though like it's all like stuck to
the sides so like it's definitely broken
is impressive
thanks for watching
[Music]